[تصفيق]
مسيرة العدالة هكذا بررها
زعيم فاغنر يفغيني بريغوسيان
للآخرين مثل الزعيم الروسي بوتين
نفسه، كانت هذه خيانة خط أحمر لا
يجرؤ الكثيرون على تجاوزه كل من
اختار عمدا طريق الخيانة
الذين أعدوا تمردًا مسلحًا اختاروا  إن
طريق الابتزاز والأساليب الإرهابية
سيواجه عقابًا لا مفر منه
وسيواجه القانون وشعبنا
بنفس السرعة التي
أصبحت بها الانتفاضة حقيقة، وتم
التوصل إلى اتفاق مع الرئيس البيلاروسي
بينما يبدو الوضع نزع فتيله في
الوقت الحالي، حيث تجرأ الكثير من الذين تجرأوا على التحدي  دفع بوتين
ثمنا باهظا
لمنتقد الكرملين الشرس، بوريس نيمسوف، الذي
كان في يوم من الأيام أحد
قادة المعارضة الواعدين في روسيا، الذي سُجن عدة مرات
بسبب تحدثه علنًا ضد
حكومة بوتين، لكن في ليلة جمعة في عام 2015، على بعد
خطوات فقط من الكرملين،
قُتل نيمسوف بالرصاص، وتم إسكات صوت معارض.
أُدين خمسة رجال شيشانيين في وقت لاحق وأُرسلوا إلى السجن لأكثر من عقد من الزمن
معارضين لحكم بوتين الذي
هدد مؤسسته
ويمكن أن تتحول الحياة إلى حياة خلف القضبان بمجرد أن
تجاوز أغنى رجل في روسيا قطب النفط السابق ميخائيل هوراكوفسكي
الخط مع بوتين عندما بدأ في  روج
للإصلاحات واتهمه بالفساد.
اتُهم هودوركوفسكي بالاحتيال الضريبي، وهي
تهمة يقول إنها ذات دوافع سياسية
لبوتين، ثم سُئل رئيس الوزراء
عن القضية فأجاب أن اللص
يجب أن يكون في السجن،
وقد مُنح أقصى عقوبة بالسجن لمنتقد الكرملين
و  أمضى سنوات خلف القضبان
[موسيقى]
سقط زعيم معارضة روسي قوي ينتقد بوتين في غيبوبة أثناء
رحلة عودته إلى موسكو قبل ثلاث سنوات،
وتم نقله لاحقًا إلى ألمانيا حيث
تعافى، وخلصت التحقيقات لاحقًا إلى
أنه تعرض للتسمم بغاز الأعصاب الذي
تعهد به نافالني.  لمواصلة محاربة
تهديد المعارضة للكرملين،
وعندما عاد إلى روسيا بعد
أشهر، تم القبض عليه واحتجازه
في سجن شديد الحراسة ويواجه
نافالني تمديدًا لفترة
يمكن أن يراه خلف القضبان لعقود من
الزمن، إنه مشهد مصيري عدة مرات
عندما  شخص ما يتخطى السيد بوتين
ولا يمكن للجميع الهروب منه ولا حتى العيش في
المنفى. ربما يكون إيفجيني براغوسان قد
وجد ملاذًا في بيلاروسيا في الوقت الحالي، لكن
سلامته تبدو هشة في أحسن الأحوال من
بلوتكين سي إن إن برلين
الخارجية